this is a day about women and this is a  movement started by young women  this young woman Masha who lost her life  fighting for women Liberty and life and  freedom this is an important message for  all of us to continue to carry on  [Music]  I think it's just a challenge for us to  find a place in the Sun and I think the  conversation and the last over the last  decade maybe not even decade I think is  in service of giving us  for everybody just to move up a little  bit because we can all share it it's big  enough it's not a question of a lack of  talent a lack of an initiative it's it's  that all those things are there we just  we we need to maybe stop asking so  nicely  uh and just kind of elbow our way in  there you know